[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: The actual
moonshot is wonderful,
inspirational, poetic,
beautiful, involved.
Great technical challenges,
genuine heroism.
It brought the world together.
But think about the Polynesian
islander on the dugout canoe,
deciding one day they were
going to that way.
No one had ever been
that way before.
No one even knew if there was
anything that way before.
It was amazing, and it
changed the world.
MALE SPEAKER: People can set
their minds to magical,
seemingly impossible ideas.
And then through science
and technology,
bring them to reality.
And that then sets other people
on fire, that other
things that look impossible
might be accomplishable.
MEGAN SMITH: Galileo's such
a hero in thinking big.
And what he represents to me is
both curiosity and wonder
that humanity had that he had
that pushed him and drove
himself to invent and work on
the first telescopes that
allowed us to see the moon.
And here we are.
MALE SPEAKER: These aviation
pioneers were figuring it out
as they went.
No one really knew how to build
an airplane, right?
No one knew how to
fly an airplane.
It was amazing and crazy
and wonderful, and
they wanted to explore.
JOHN F. KENNEDY: Many years
ago, the great British
explorer George Mallory,
who was to die on Mt.
Everest, was asked, why did
he want to climb it?
He said because it is there.
MEGAN SMITH: There are so many
challenges in the world.
And you can feel daunted by that
and oppressed by that.
Or you kind of say,
how might we think
differently about this?
MALE SPEAKER: Everyone else
in the world is working
on that next 10%.
If you can be the one that
delivers that 10 times
improvement, you have a chance
to really change things.
MALE SPEAKER: If you want
cars to run at 50
miles per gallon, fine.
You can retool your
car a little bit.
But if I tell you it has to run
on a gallon of gas for 500
miles, you have to start over.
MEGAN SMITH: You need a lot of
courage in this work and you
need a lot of persistence.
One of the things that's really
critical is not only
having the courage to
keep trying every
day or thinking big.
Even if you don't really 100%
believe it's possible, you
might think, this might
be possible.
Have the courage to try.
That's how the greatest
things have happened.
MALE SPEAKER: You don't spend
your time being bothered that
you can't teleport from here
to Japan because there's a
part of you that thinks
it's impossible.
Moonshot thinking is choosing
to be bothered by that.
JOHN F. KENNEDY: We choose to go
to the moon in this decade
and do the other things.
Not because they are easy, but
because they are hard.
MALE SPEAKER: Humanity's
progress has been a series of
amazing, audacious things from
the very small and personal up
to the great big and
grand, and we are
a species of moonshots.
And to me, that's the really
amazing, poetic,
inspirational thing.
MALE SPEAKER: I think our
ambitions are a glass ceiling
in what we can accomplish.
MEGAN SMITH: When you find
your passion, you're
unstoppable.
You can make amazing
things happen.
It's been true through
all of history.
MALE SPEAKER: I believe
in the human spirit.
And I believe that there are
always going to be crazy
people who get out of
bed one morning and
say, you know what?
I think I can build
a space cylinder.
And they'll just go do it.
But I think that if we become
afraid to take these great big
risks, we stop inspiring
people.
We stop achieving things.
And the biggest nightmare
scenario is that we won't have
what it takes to solve the
really big challenges.
MALE SPEAKER: When Kennedy said
that we would put a man
on the moon, it's about the fact
that he said, we don't
know how to do this yet.
And we're going to
do it anyway.
And that sends chills up
everybody's spine.
Because if that happens,
what couldn't we do?
MALE SPEAKER: And cue.
LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live at I/O.
Welcome Megan Smith.
MEGAN SMITH: Thank you.
It's great to be here.
LOUIS GRAY: Thank you
for joining me.
I'm really excited
about moonshots.
We've been talking about some
really incredible things.
We just heard from Larry about
all the work that Google has
been doing.
We've heard from Vic and Sundar,
and really trying to
change the world through
technology.
Can you tell me a little bit
about what a moonshot is?
MEGAN SMITH: Sure.
Sometimes we think of it as 10
X better versus 1 X better.
And in fact, we just
watched this film
with some of us talking.
Often, doing a 10 X can be, not
easier, but easier than
you think than 1 X. We
just try to look at--
I think I have a graphic.
We launched a thing called Solve
for X, which is trying
to get more moonshot thinking
in the world.
And sometimes you think
about, there's a huge
problem in the world.
If we put up that graphic
there's three circles.
Technology that maybe it appears
like science fiction,
but it's coming online or
there's a new way to think
about some technology, and let's
apply it in some way.
Not unlike the original
moonshot.
We want to get here by the end
of the decade, get started,
start with Mercury and move.
LOUIS GRAY: And the initiative
Solve for X really tries to
solve global problems.
One thing that really excited
me about Google in the first
place was that we take on these
things that people say
is impossible.
How do we let the
impossibility of
things get in the way?
What do people say that they
can't do, and what do you
think makes Google a
great place to say,
yes, we can do this?
MEGAN SMITH: We stand on the
shoulders of giants and
amazing moonshot folks.
I'm from Buffalo, New York
where Nikola Tesla took a
moonshot to use Niagara Falls to
light Buffalo years ago to
demo modern electrification.
So many people have been
thinking like that, but it
maybe hasn't been
the majority.
And certainly Larry and Sergey
in founding Google thought
about, what's the big idea?
What we can do?
They were passionate, of course,
about Search in the
beginning but have taken us
in a lot of directions.
I think also in some ways
there's some moonshot work
around how we do our work,
how we collaborate.
I love that Larry just did
a full open Q&A, very--
transparency is a fundamental
thing, and collaboration.
LOUIS GRAY: That's something
that's really important to us
in Google Developers Live.
I want to break those barriers
down so all of the people on
the live stream can not only
see us and talk to us, but
engage with us and have that
kind of Q&A that we honestly
get as employees from Google.
To hear from Larry, it's really
exciting to see Larry
and all the other engineers
engaging with developers here.
When I look at Google and
we talk about moonshots,
obviously things like
self-driving cars come to
mind, and other bits
like Gmail.
It wasn't too long ago
that Gmail came out.
It came out on April Fools'
Day of all things.
I didn't even know
if it was real.
But they promised us a whole
gigabyte of email when
everyone else was offering
20 or 40 megs.
What is your thought in terms
of what are some moonshots
that Google's done so far, and
what comes to mind in terms of
something that we can
really deliver on
to change the world?
MEGAN SMITH: Well there's a
range of moonshots that
Googlers have taken.
And I always think that
moonshots are both the idea
and the people, or the team.
Who and what are
never separate.
You know Maps and Geo would
be a good example.
This incredible team of Keyhole
and Where2 Tech, other
small acquisitions we've made.
And the teams came and we got
together and really pushed it
and wanted to have free full
mapping to everybody.
And some of things we've just
seen demonstrated are on that
path of really thinking big.
LOUIS GRAY: I know you
talk about big.
It's really incredible to think
about the millions of
miles that are in Street View,
and the fact that just a few
years ago, you wouldn't have
thought of having the entire
globe in a little smartphone in
your pocket that you take
with you everywhere.
And the moonshot really takes
the impossible, the
incredible, and makes it real,
and makes it happen.
For somebody who's going to the
Solve for X website, how
can they get started?
What is it that they can do to
find other people with similar
dreams like them?
MEGAN SMITH: Right.
On our website the main
thing is we want
people to put up proposals.
What are their moonshots?
We want to celebrate
people and process.
Of course we want the historic
stuff and hear what great
people have done and inspire
us that way.
But also let's help people and
teams and process, and let's
get inspired by each other
to think of new things.
So a lot of things to watch
and collaborate on there.
And in general, Larry's
saying, think big.
That's what we're
trying to do.
The other thing that we're
trying to do is that ideas
come from everywhere.
Bill Clinton says, 21st century
is really about
creative collaboration.
Back to the Maps example, we are
doing things in Maps but
then there's things where people
are adding edits and
things on top, layers,
amazing innovations.
Ushahidi is such a fabulous
innovation on top of mapping
to help with crisis
around the world.
So collaboration together,
and I love that we're on
Developers Live, because
it's all about the
interconnection of us.
I have to give a talk
this summer.
It's called the next greatest
generation.
I think the next greatest
generation is actually all of
us networked.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
And so one thing, [INAUDIBLE]
we looked at Google.
Google's a business.
We're not a nonprofit.
Is it possible to do a moonshot
without first
thinking of revenue?
Like, how can we do something
that is not only incredible,
but does it have
to make money?
How do you separate the business
side of things from
the actual want to change the
world ideals of doing things?
MEGAN SMITH: I always think
there's for profit, nonprofit.
But there always needs to be
revenue coming towards
something even if it's gifted
revenue, donations, or
philanthropic, or
kickstarterly things or others.
So I think the most important
thing is not to start with the
money, to start with
the big idea.
We did that with Google,
we've done that
with so many products.
And then the money can follow
if it's incredibly valuable.
And sometimes innovating how the
money should follow is a
big part of the design.
The internet is such an
example of freemium.
It's the idea that free things
and then add ways to pay for
some part, or media-based
advertising, et cetera.
So there's a lot of different
models out there
that you can use.
But I think the most important
thing is find something you're
really passionate about doing
and something that's really
needed in the world.
Those two things together let
the business plan follow that.
LOUIS GRAY: As Vice President
of Google x, you see
incredible things every day.
Things that the world knows
about, things that I know
about, and then things that
almost nobody knows about.
And you must have an incredibly
busy time.
Now, what else are you doing at
Google I/O in addition to
speaking with us today?
MEGAN SMITH: The Google X team
is here with Google Glass, of
course, and Larry was
talking about the
self-driving car ambitions.
And then we have a lot of other
things we're thinking
about and working on.
We're still cooking them,
they're still early.
So we're working on those.
And then of course Solve for
X, sort of sharing this.
I'm also personally working
a lot on diversity.
And we have a session later
today at 5:30 on live stream
that I hope people join, Seven
Tech Makers and a Microphone.
The Women Tech Makers
Live at [? I/O. ?]
LOUIS GRAY: We've had a number
of sessions on Women Tech
Makers on GDL.
It's been really a key focus for
us to make sure that we're
highlighting incredible women.
I was really pleased to make
sure that you went first and
would be our first guest.
Not because you're a woman but
because you are an incredible
executive who has a proven track
record, who happens to
be a woman.
And you're doing a lot of great
stuff with WTM as we
call it, with Woman
Tech Makers.
And I'm glad that that's been
an incredible focus.
MEGAN SMITH: Yeah, and Larry was
just answering a question
about getting more girls and
boys, but girls into STEM
technologies.
There are so many jobs open that
we don't have people for.
We need a lot of people to
come into our field.
And a friend of mine, Nicholas
[? Nicaponi ?]
once said, have you
ever had a job?
Meaning this is passion
work that we do.
It's not required work.
And so for young people
to know about this
work is really important.
And the visibility of technical
women is important.
Because technical women, for
whatever reason through media
and others, have not been as
visible as they should be.
Including later today, we're
going to talk about a history
story at 5:30 Pacific that
nobody has ever heard, pretty
much at [? scale ?], so
that should be fun.
LOUIS GRAY: For sure.
Well I definitely appreciate
you coming and
talking with me.
We're going to be producing a
lot of exclusive interviews
with Googlers throughout
the day.
On Google Developers Live, we're
going to be highlighting
some of our partners in the
sandboxes and we have a lot
more content.
What we're going to be doing
right next is we're going to
be going back to the sessions,
so start to see the live
sessions from all of the streams
that you're looking at
from Android, Chrome, and
other technical topics.
And then we'll be right back
here at the GDL at I/O stage
around 1:30 to talk about
Blink with Chrome.
So thank you very much, Megan.
MEGAN SMITH: Thanks Louis and
thanks everyone online for
joining us.